今天台灣股市漲了337點
投資朋友 你可能會覺得說
今天反彈又怎麼樣
反彈沒有量 6400億
怎麼會這樣子
台灣股市反彈沒有量
是不是空頭訊號 你最想要知道
第二個 漢測抽籤結束了
被凍結8000多億的資金
明天解凍了
台灣股市明天會不會爆量
明天爆量的機率很高 為什麼
因為明天還要卡在
升息機率 凌晨2點如果確定升息
會不會利空出盡
是利空出盡還是台股是核爆
這一切的一切我一次預告清楚
預告在前
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
郭哲榮分析師
也是全台灣唯一100萬粉絲訂閱
不只 140萬粉絲訂閱的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
你沒有聽過哲哲
你一定是股市菜鳥中的菜鳥 來
今天我們來看一下
今天台灣股市真的很無聊
可是我感覺快要
黑暗已過 黎明要來了
好不好 劉德華也通通都要來了
這是老笑話
年輕人應該不知道我說什麼
有時候太老的笑話
很多人不一定喜歡
所以我們要跟上
趕快講比較多K-POP會比較好 來
開玩笑的
我們來看一下這個行情
今天台灣股市硬是拉 有沒有
至少是有一點有沒有
當沖順勢盤有一點點啦
至少早盤是一個低點
還滿準的對不對
我今天期貨要掛
差點就賺到錢了 氣死了
沒有關係 沒有掛到沒關係
可是至少我們趨勢對了
當沖順勢盤沒有錯吧
當然期貨是高風險的
不一定要做啦 好不好
喜歡賭的人可以去做期貨好不好
我們來看一下
我講的是期貨的大台 多空單
或小台都可以
今天韓國股市還是有漲了1.3%
你們看現在股票
今天股票有些不錯
台積電怎麼看
台積電就是適合睡覺用的 什麼意思
你就睡個1年 半年
醒來台積電3000塊
台積電4000塊了
我講的3年10萬點
其實3年股市可以漲250%
很厲害耶
巴菲特績效還不一定這麼好
那問題是
那代表天天漲嗎 不是喔
我們看一下台積電的走勢
每天要提醒這些
台積電走勢
跟大盤走勢一樣有沒有看到
休息一陣子有沒有看到
在這邊就休息一陣子有沒有
區間整理平台
這是去年的
這個是 我們看一下台積電
他在這邊休息
休息這一陣子有沒有看到
都沒有動 1400上下有沒有看到
在這邊晃啊晃
突然一根漲起來
然後再慢慢的漲
突然急漲 有沒有看到
他都突然一陣急漲有沒有看到
他都會先區間整理平台
然後再急漲
所以大盤你要能度過這一段時機
那怎麼度過 很簡單
當你想要賣股票的時候
看哲哲的節目
你就發現人生充滿光明
很多人喜歡看我的節目
尤其孤單 無聊 孤獨的時候
看哲哲的節目最棒
有最新的財經知識
有最多最新奇的AI知識
我再講一件事情
除了我以外
有誰說下一代AI會很恐怖
有誰在前年就跟你講
大前年 2023年說
AI股會漲1年或甚至漲3年
有誰在去年26000的時候
年底26000
說喊今年36000到40000
那時候沒有人相信
一位都沒有
有誰在台灣股市跌破40000點的時候
跟你講我要買1億台灣50
馬上就賺1000多萬了
誰 通通都是我
連續3年買台灣50
公開這樣砸錢
都買在相對低點
都跌好幾千點的時候買
所以你們在行情不好的時候
要看我的節目
現在行情很無聊對不對
沒有關係 年底快到了
最好做股票的是年底
為什麼 我記得很清楚
因為每次都是我生日的時候
不要看哲哲年輕
已經當分析師當了20年了
好不好 這個跟大家講
趕快把握住這個行情
你看這邊又在晃嘛
晃到你想睡覺有沒有
因為2500
我也跟大家講
我說那時候你不如換00981A
台積電是個優點也是個缺點 好不好
拉遠一點 都沒在動
再拉近一點沒關係
沒在動 就在這個區間整理平台
根本沒在動
2200到2500
這個區間而已
台積電最近很有名 知不知道
P12廠 很有名
兩個論及婚嫁的人
這個八卦 算了 不要講
網路上我看一看
哲哲現在變成
Threads的重度使用者
不過那個說老實話
兩個人就是
講到八卦 P12廠
有人什麼結婚
然後未婚妻抓包
還有人說去投訴公司
可是我覺得這個八卦是可以
但是跟工作能力是兩回事
當然有些人喜歡吃瓜
扯遠了
這會不會影響台積電股價
當然不會
好啦 聽不懂就算了
聽得懂就知道有這些東西
現在的人很喜歡吃瓜
來 我們看一下
那個台股反彈無量 空頭訊號
絕對不是 好不好
我可以舉很多
都是量很縮的時候噴出去
看一下
前陣子有沒有
這邊是不是量縮
我這次 我在這邊買
這個前一天就量縮
拉遠
前一天就量縮
量縮以後怎麼樣
股市直接噴出去
噴了7000點
所以量縮不重要
量縮痛苦是誰
是分析師 是券商
券商經理人 券商營業員
這樣懂不懂
是元大證券
是群益 是投顧業 摩爾投顧
業績越好的影響越多
因為比例不同
我們同樣是1%
我們就是怎麼樣
餓死的駱駝比馬大
當然不會到那麼誇張
沒到說不景氣
只是說影響的業績一定差比較多
摩爾投顧是業績最大
不相信的話去打聽
這個沒有人會否認這個事實
所以我常常回到一句話
你們不選最大最紅的投顧公司
最紅的分析師
你要選誰
要選就選最紅的
你們家有沒有
好不好 OK嗎
不紅一定有不紅的道理
紅一定有紅的道理
當然我們不會特地去跟你講這些東西
我們也不要去攻擊誰
可是我跟你講
至少我本身絕對不會像別家投顧
CPO強講CPO
光學強講光學
記憶體強講記憶體
反正每天都可以買到最強勢的股票
這個你聽聽就好
我是不會做這種事情
然後我也不想針對誰 好不好
我不需要針對誰
你們只要記得兩件事情
第一個
老投顧的事情你們不要選
第二個 會攻擊分析師的分析師
也不要選
那一定業績不好
你去想想業績會多好
好的話會像我一樣很忙
沒時間去看人家的節目
分析師是分析股票
不是分析分析師的
不過我還是要每天提醒一分鐘
自從有人攻擊以後
你們都看到
攻擊我的身體變不好
攻擊我的視網膜剝離
攻擊我的心臟不好
所以最近陳建州
不是差點心肌梗塞嗎
那個就是一樣 怎麼樣
就是LDL
我跟大家講
陳建州嘛 黑人嘛
就是你看他才多少歲
可能才50歲不到而已
你看還可以灌籃
身高190幾
體態很好 很瘦 為什麼
從頭到尾不是你的體態
膽固醇7成以上
是你身體分泌的 懂不懂
天生的基因決定一切
那膽固醇越多了
越容易中風
在這邊叫心肌梗塞
在這邊叫腦中風
這樣懂不懂 OK嗎
所以這個我早就跟大家講說
就是要把LDL降到55以下
好幾年前我跟別的醫生講
有些醫生不相信
只有少部分醫生相信
現在越來越多人認同 好不好
外面的學術研究就是這樣子
所以把三高治好
把命變長一點
賺錢才有意義 好不好
這個我常常跟大家講
我現在是變成預言家
加上心靈大師
有沒有感受到我的心靈
再一次
有吧 OK嗎
可是我心靈的大師
不是像有些人裝神弄鬼
我是有科學根據的
還是要講 AI泡沫
之前講AI泡沫
跟AI會毀滅人類
這是兩回事
基本上是有點互斥的
基本上
川普說AI危害
就是AI會怎樣
會毀滅全世界是騙局 OK
是不是 這個我昨天就跟你講了
那你去想一件事
AI可以掌控全世界
毀滅人類 殺了人
那是不是代表AI無所不能
AI既然無所不能
你又討論那投資AI會收不了錢
因為現在最多是基礎建設
我投資一年
四大CSP我可能投資
這些亞馬遜 Google相關的
我可能會投資這些台積電的晶片
買雲端伺服器
買AI伺服器
我要花到一兆美元
接下來幾年花一兆美元
那怎麼變現了
花一兆美元怎麼收回錢呢
很多人在討論這件事情
也是讓股市漲不上去
都可以毀滅全世界
然後會賺不了錢
那個是很極端的好不好
一個是過度投資
一個是進步太快
如果你在討論會毀滅人類
基本上就不會有
他進步很慢這回事
沒錯吧
所以邏輯要對
這是我一直要跟大家講的事情
所以你要想一件事
我很多東西邏輯都是很對的
為什麼很多工程師喜歡看我的節目
為什麼
看起來台積電那個12廠
會不會大家講八卦
為什麼很多工程師
當然我們也會討論到啦
很多台積電工程師
都會想要跟我講八卦
為什麼很多工程師都會參加我的會員
邏輯好啊
他們不喜歡邏輯不好的人好不好
這個跟大家講 來
這幾天抽個寂寞
不會啦 我跟你講
我現在真的覺得
那個融資不錯 不是融資
就是質押 不要亂質押
可是你為了抽籤而質押
目前為止我是贊同的
因為風險極低
但是最後風險要自負
我是合法分析師
我不會跟你講說百分之百穩賺的
沒有這回事
市場上也不會有人講
講這個東西基本上都詐騙集團 好不好
哲哲以前讀書
應該是那種會教同學的好人
還好耶 我以前不是壞人
但我也不是非常無私的
我覺得我無私
是這幾年越來越多 真的啦
我覺得我最跟人家不一樣的是
我會常常反省自己
所以我有時候在僱用員工的時候
我也會看
很多人都不了解
反省自己很重要
吾日三省吾身
我差不多五省吧
還有一次睡醒 好不好
哲哲40幾歲
不然你覺得我幾歲
還沒50這樣好不好 來
公益直播 不用按讚
公益直播要按讚啦
這樣講我要生氣了
沒關係 這個是好笑
來按讚
我以為哲哲才35是不是
不好意思 有在健身
我最近身材也健得不錯 好不好
我都希望訓練到
那種水炸彈的男嘉賓
那種六塊肌
開玩笑的 那很難
哲哲是明哲保身的學生
就不是壞人
但是我以前脾氣比較差
我現在脾氣越來越好
當然還是沒有到很好
原來哲哲18歲就考上分析師
現在38歲
沒有 我20幾歲來
怎麼可能18歲來
漢測有抽中的
舉手讓我們羨慕一下
趕快有抽中的跟我講一下好不好 來
有人說有後悔嗎
有人後悔有人愛啦 好不好 沒關係
黑人 抽籤 大牙
黑人也中
中了啊 所以剛才說
三高治好 長命百歲
天天睡好覺長命百歲 來
新高量
要選就選最神的 不就是哲哲
來啦 5萬點相信我啦
真的年底會5萬點好不好
今天期貨多單好像多了6800多口
但是那不是最新的
助理是最新的嗎
2點55分看起來是最新的
來 我們看一下
空單減少6800口
近期新低
助理幫我看一下是不是近期新低
但是現在期貨空單已經不準
在2007年的時候
那時候我剛考上分析師的時候
還沒有人知道要看期貨空單
那時候外資
那時候證交所
你可以問期交所的人
期交所那時候是先模擬 還不公布
模擬你可以查得到
我不懂為什麼不直接公布
2007年就可以查到了
所以2007年我靠金融海嘯
我自己操作啦
因為那時候金融海嘯的時候
剛好失業
所以你看我很多苦難都有經過
可是失業我反而自己做股票
反而賺很多
這個跟大家講
所以我操作股票30年的經驗
來 所以那時候期貨空單很準
現在期貨空單不準了
因為權值太重了 太多是避險
那時候大概2萬口空單
1萬口就嚇嚇叫
2萬口基本上就是要做空
做空必勝
現在完全沒有觀察性
對 我忘記跟你講
哲哲是稱號太多
還有經濟日報188
以前找主持人最主要是要念這一段
不過後來覺得我還是自己念
因為我覺得不是
說老實話
不是每個人能跟上哲哲的腳步
這樣我會要求人家比較嚴格
真的啦 這自己也要改
所以我跟大家講
我很多口號 扯遠了
我很多口號 我還有期貨分析師
不是每個人有期貨分析師
來 期貨分析師來看一下
空單少了6800
變成76000
近期新低 助理幫我查一下
這有利於行情
但是這個不會加分
選項加分不會加很多
今天取決於 來
晚上的升息 來看一下
這個最重要
當然這個都說老實話
這個是治標不治本
升不升息
問題是如果柴油再漲
怎麼辦 還是會有能源危機
好不好
布蘭特原油或是十年期公債都在漲
00687B是不是
真的是有夠87
我今天看一下
不看還好 看了會中風
00687B 還原比較好一點
破新低
美債有賠錢的
應該基本上都不是我的忠實粉絲
美債會賠錢的 現在還會賠錢的
應該基本上不是我的忠實粉絲
還有我賠而已
所以說當分析師是不是少賺很多
我要是那個1.74億的美債
拿去換台灣50
現在至少4億
我沒跟你開玩笑
你們自己算算看
那時候我想換
大家說不行 哲哲這樣子說謊話
這個跟大家講
沒關係啦
誰叫我那時候答應大家
說要賺2000萬才走
可是如果你們
其實美債還是可以換台灣50
任何時段都可以換 好不好
這個就代表
為什麼美債跌
因為那個通膨起來
因為殖利率上升
那殖利率上升 通膨起來了
那就要升息
你不升息 是不是
壓不住通膨
這樣懂不懂
你這個利率
這個Fed所定的利率
包括台灣央行所定的利率
一定要高過通膨
不高過通膨 你變惡性的通膨
那大家錢幹嘛放在銀行
或有相關的金融危機
長期而言會變成惡性的通膨
記得我這個邏輯
聽不懂的
總體經濟大概學這個
你就贏了90%的人
很多人學一堆
實際的運行什麼
這個是影響股市最重要的東西
那你還有一升息的資金怎麼樣
還有公債殖利率一提高了
我現在到5% 10%了
假設我到10%了
我幹嘛買股票
現在已經很多人
覺得做股票很難做了
你懂不懂
大部分人都看很短
不是每個人像我看那麼長
所以資金又會抽離股市
去往債市走
這時候又會怎麼樣
不好意思 又會跌
你懂不懂 又會跌
所以這個邏輯
要記得我這些東西 好不好
哲哲都講在前面 好不好
再看一下你們今天的對話
來 要按讚
愛哲哲按讚喔 按一下
上班偷看一下 也按讚 是不是
上班偷約會喔
會被公審
偷看哲哲的不會
你也是看哲哲的節目喔
加息了怎麼還能達到5萬點
這是好問題
如果一直加息
那5萬點的確會 應該說
這股市最大的動盪就是升息危機
我從頭到尾就這樣講喔
我講了至少10次以上喔
我說AI不是泡沫
AI沒有問題
股市最大的問題是通膨的問題
我有講喔
我一直講喔 我今年一直講喔
所以你的邏輯是對的
所以如果會
可是我還是覺得會上5萬點
只是這個上5萬點的過程中
會比較顛簸
OK嗎 Understand
因為他今年在升息
頂多升息兩次啊 不用擔心
只是5萬到10萬的過程中
如果一直升下去
可能會崩盤
比如說漲到6萬點
再給你崩到5萬點
你懂不懂 這是有可能的
如果再升息下去 好不好
台積電12廠的員工
會看哲哲的節目嗎
來 舉手 一定很多人
OK 來
哲哲寶貝請幫我分析
你女兒現在念財經嘛
他想轉化學系
怕沒有念化學以後會後悔
這怎麼看
老實話 財經系的出路
沒有很寬啦
所以財經轉化學不錯
你看他要不要轉化學
但是化學其實也可以在台積電工作啦
這個現在所有的人才都跑去台積電了
那我覺得他有興趣
那就OK啊
這位媽媽不要擔心
你兒孫自有兒孫福
財經系的路不會比較寬 OK嗎
重點是要有興趣
像我對股票有興趣
我雖然是閱讀障礙
你叫我去
我現在發現
幸好我以前成績不夠好
沒有考到一個政大法律
閱讀障礙
閱讀障礙叫我每天看法條
我會痛苦死
所以人生沒有一定
上帝把你關上門 會幫你開扇窗
千萬不要把那關上的門
一定要打開
你後來發現是一個牆壁
你會想要撞牆 真的
記得我這句話
哲哲我們辦公室大螢幕直播
接你直播
大螢幕直接接你直播
老闆是你的粉絲
你們老闆識貨 你懂不懂
叫你的老闆看一下
因為如果不小心本業不賺錢的時候
靠我的業外賺錢
開玩笑的啦
祝你業外業內都賺錢 好不好
18歲的大帥哥
講男生18歲沒有很開心
講18什麼 18禁的話 開玩笑
導播笑什麼
男生沒有需要年輕
不像女生好不好
OK嗎 來
哲哲可以秀一下肌肉
幹嘛啦 這肌肉OK吧
有啦 最近有變寬了
你們不覺得肩膀有變寬嗎
不好意思 其實我跟你講
我跟你講話的時候
我都彎腰駝背
我怕我太挺胸你們會嫉妒
開玩笑的啦 好啦
FOMC的推背圖
沒有 這一次沒有
上次有跟你講
CPI 3.4%就漲嘛 對不對
後來真的漲了嘛
只是禮拜一又有AI毀滅論
來 這禮拜最重要的是
是要升息的問題
只要升息確定以後
然後FOMC會議以後他只要講說
OK 我們就是
他稍微委婉一點說
我們先升息一次再看看
就是沒有一定要第二次一定要升息
我們現在要看的是第二次升息
來看一下
我們12月9號對不對
現在你看這個利率很重要
現在我們利率是大概3.5
美國的利率是3.5到3.75
比台灣利率高很多
3.5到3.75有沒有
9月16號就是明天凌晨2點
公布的升息的機率
再升息一碼的機率是92% 好
他如果跟你講說再觀察
12月他如果到時候給你觀察的對話
讓你覺得12月再升息一碼 有沒有
現在從3.5到3.75
變成3.75到4對不對
就是升息一碼
如果再升息再一碼 就兩碼了
兩碼子的事情 你知道嗎
台積電12廠這個紛爭
也是兩碼子的事情
兩個馬子 吵架 冷笑話
升息兩碼
一個碼 兩個碼
升息第二碼的機率大幅下滑
或下滑一點點
這應該嚴格來說不是49
是差不多49加30 是80%
因為這是兩碼 這是三碼
這樣懂不懂
升息三碼當然經過兩碼 OK嗎
12月升息兩碼的機率
比如說本來現在80%
兩碼超過80%
因為加起來 你懂嗎
因為這是升息三碼
升息兩碼以上的機率這兩個都含了
從80%降到60% 50%
股市會噴出去
就depends on
決定於這個華許
Fed新任主席的言論
有沒有稍微鴿一點點
知道嗎 哥 你好
這樣懂不懂
這是今天最重要的
其他的不重要
其他剛才跟你喇低賽 好不好
可是這是治標不治本
重點的本是什麼
戰爭不要打 OK嗎
這個跟大家講 OK嗎
戰爭不要打
然後原油價格下去
好不好 OK嗎
10月28日若升息
11月初期中選舉是不是不想選
你說如果有8%不升息對不對
那股市 這個很難預測
股市會不會覺得
來 不升息是不是好
不一定喔 為什麼
因為當大家市場覺得你要升息
你不升息
除非你要很好的理論敘述它
說我看不出來通膨的問題
可是你不升息
反而大家有可能會崩
哲哲 你怎麼這樣討論
但是我這是討論8%的事情
你記得我的邏輯
就像我講為什麼很多人喜歡看我的節目
邏輯很重要
因為市場會覺得說你不聽話
市場會覺得你該升息而不升息
會醞釀更大的錯誤
除非你能說服市場
股票市場的持有人
Fed能說服市場
我這次不升息
是我看到明確的訊號
通膨要下來了
不然你如果要不升息
本來預期要升息的
凌晨2點預期要升息
明天凌晨2點預期要升息
但是他不升息
那不好意思
那股市不一定是以利多視之
我先跟大家講
這個我很難預測
他有可能是以利多視之
有可能利空視之
哲哲你這樣講 有講跟沒講一樣
這件事情的確邏輯上是這樣子
可是重點是要我的邏輯推演好不好
OK嗎
可是我覺得升息完以後
然後稍微配鴿派的
這個漲的機率非常高
記得我的邏輯好不好
股市就是這麼好玩
可是你從頭到尾
我的邏輯推論是對的 OK嗎
現在跟剛開戰的石油飆漲不同
這兩個月油價還壓得下去
是因為全球許多國家用戰備用油
對啊 壓不下去怎麼辦
壓不下去川普就會
其實我跟你講
到最後川普還是會吞下去
為什麼
沒有為什麼
因為就像越戰一樣
你美國人只要不願意犧牲你的肉體
尊貴的肉體
你只用轟炸是沒有辦法
你用轟炸是沒有辦法
就算你深入敵營
像越南你都沒辦法
人家就像中國人講的
我們中國可以吃草 你怎麼辦
怎麼跟我打 是啊
講事實 好不好 OK嗎
封鎖就舒服了
問題是原油價格
其實你看
現在為什麼連紅海都打
為了要讓你受不了
不升息代表有大家沒看到的
那得要說服市場 就像我講的
那不一定
聯準會不升息才慘
歐日都連續升息
對 這個反而會變得也不太好
大家會覺得不合理
就是這個很難預告
我很難講好不好
快衝2000讚比較實際
我喜歡你這句話
來看多少讚
不覺得堂堂一位
140萬的粉絲的分析師
然後每天要拜託按個讚
不要這樣子
哲哲也收不多
一個月只要收個500 100
100 這樣我是不是應該要收費
以後搞成那個對不對
我收個不簡單
我收500就好
除了會員以外 我收個500
那我影片來個20萬
1000萬耶
下個月這樣做好了
反正大家都不按讚
500塊
連500塊都付不起的
那就是你不想付而已
做股票都不只這個錢
對不對 沒錯吧
不是1000萬耶
20萬的人觀看嘛 500嘛
是不是 1億耶
我有沒有算錯 真的
是不是 還是我算錯了
對 1億
那我收50就好 1000萬
500我看你會不會
那我收100就好了 2000萬
這樣不錯吧
你開心我也開心
那你到時候你要不要按讚
我都不管你好不好
趕快按讚啦
到時候收100就好了 2000萬
一個影片大概200萬人看
而且收100你們也比較不會抱怨
100也不會特別要求 特別什麼
不用拜託 我自發按讚
哲哲不缺錢
我是不缺錢
我缺感覺你懂不懂
我缺情緒價值
女生不是這樣講嗎
當我情緒崩潰的時候
你有沒有接住我
女生不是這樣講這個嗎
你要接住我的情緒啊 各位
好啦 不錯喔
這麼無聊的行情
還可以自言自語的
這麼順的就只有我
來看一下啦
看一下國巨啦
你們自己算一下
我沒有100多萬人看我的節目
除非大行情的時候幾十萬
可是20萬人有啦
100 訂閱我頻道的100
每個訂閱我頻道
以後就是付費的
才能看我的付費影片
100乘上20萬
一個月2000萬
這樣子我OK
我可以搞訂閱制
然後每個月捐救護車
也不錯 還划算
還賺1500萬
雖然救護車很貴
我真的很會算的話 我更有錢
我只是不想算而已 OK
這個跟大家講
來看一下台勝科有沒有
我是不是說昨天那個利多消息
本來就是大利多
我說昨天怎麼不反應
莫名其妙 是不是 來
國巨 看一下國巨
先看一下環球晶
按讚 按讚 按讚
講這樣子恐嚇你們
還是你們願意付100
看一下按讚
看來要恐嚇 要直接恐嚇
沒關係
不要啦 每天這樣子恐嚇你們我也累
這個改天
改天做了真的收錢
你就不要怪我
來 我們來看一下
台勝科
不會啦 那很便宜
台勝科3532
我現在沒有這個想法
也不是在鋪路
3532台勝科
它一路漲
你看這個東西
其實它基本面沒有到很好
就是如果看現在EPS
著眼於未來
你看一下 已經說缺貨了
有沒有
矽晶圓明年有望爆搶貨潮
這是我做的AI圖有沒有看到
先進製程要同步擴產
我說先進製程同步擴產
你要知道先進製程
台積電擴產需要矽晶圓
記憶體擴產也需要矽晶圓
晶圓消耗量年增11% 12%
要不要 要啊
然後AI HBM提升需求
提升需求 也要
HBM有沒有
這就是記憶體 也是我講的
記憶體也需要
HBM就是高階的雲端的記憶體
好不好 高階伺服器的記憶體
這個先進製程也需要
所以我AI伺服器越多
我是Double的
裡面的記憶體
我雲端伺服器擴產
我高階的那個AI
AI伺服器擴產
不好意思 台積電晶片要更多
還是需要我的怎麼樣
我的矽晶圓
環球晶的矽晶圓
不好意思 那擴產以後
雲端伺服器擴產
AI伺服器擴產
台積電要擴產 記憶體要擴產
這兩個通通都需要Double的
雙層的效果
都需要矽晶圓
現在庫存仍待消耗
現在庫存很高對不對
仍高於50到70天
等到庫存
現在記憶體什麼問題
記憶體全世界都知道缺貨
缺貨到明年
缺貨到後年
缺貨到2030年
可是股價漲不動
所以等到他庫存
真的一旦消化了以後
然後開始漲價
EPS還不會出現喔
等到EPS出現的時候
說老實話最好的一段已經過了
等到他被管制了 被處置了
公布你每個月EPS的時候
一直公布的時候
不好意思
那庫存水位
已經低於可能30天的時候
OK嗎
那不好意思股價
其實那時候矽晶圓
環球晶已經2000塊以上了 好不好
然後那個中美晶
已經400塊以上了
記得我的預告
你看全球月產能
2027年才增3%
人家增3%
先進製程要增12%
矽晶圓要增28%
所以代表他們擴產是很慢的
2027年 2028年缺貨潮恐現
矽晶圓景氣重返上升循環
等到那個時候你就說
哲哲 你看缺口越來越大
我跟你講來不及
那你說12吋缺口
其他的不缺
我不能把其他的廠改12吋嗎
這不是跟記憶體一樣嗎
我記憶體HBM缺啊
DRAM怎麼會漲
沒有啊 我就把產能移過去啊
這不是記憶體2.0嗎 是不是
這個村田也是一樣啊
我擴產MLCC啊
我要停產車用的啊
停產車用的被動元件啊
那這個不就是
一樣是記憶體2.0嗎
我停產這個
停產不好賺錢的
我去擴產好賺錢的
那我原本車用的也會漲價啊
原本我要去擴產這方面的
有關AI的被動元件的
也會缺啊
那車用更缺啊 都缺啊
產能移來移去
反而都缺啊
不是一樣的邏輯嗎
你們真的要開心啦
國巨我就是要證明我扛得起來
不然我來喊信昌電
我每天講信昌電早就怎麼樣
噴出去有沒有看到 信昌電
信昌電這種走法啦
結果你們覺得國巨扛不起來
遲早的啦
那個3026是不是 禾伸堂
禾伸堂也要噴出去啊
2492 要不然你買個華新科
是不是 你覺得國巨
背上很重 買個華新科
你看6173
當然你說東西 這個比重有差
但是也不應該他創新高 他沒創新高
我跟你講很聰明
中實戶 大戶就是拉信昌電
圍魏救趙
拉信昌電救信昌電
不是 拉信昌電救華邦電
說錯了
拉信昌電救華新科 救國巨
記得我這句話好不好
這是記憶體
被動元件真的很好
我認為很好賺 你要把握住
看一下這些東西預告
我都講在前面
所以今天行情喔
真的不難做
重點是明天
這一週的行情是看禮拜四 禮拜五
好不好
你看哪有老師像我們那麼認真
現在很多投顧也是學我們
學我們 學我
還有我們福利社做什麼
做這個月曆
你看我們月曆多好
去年12月的時候
我們大概11 12月會做月曆
到時候抽出來你要把握住
有些人抽出來記得要拿
不要浪費資源
你看17號 有沒有
今天是不是台指期結算
而且你看配色配得很漂亮
哲哲堅持
你看台指期結算有沒有 今天
明天凌晨兩點
Fed利率決策會議
後天美股四巫日
台灣50季度調整
好不好 這些東西
季度調整什麼東西
助理講一下 助理
你看連助理都忘記了
看一下季度調整有生效什麼
是有剔除一些 康霈嘛 還有什麼
台灣50季度調整
好像一進一出是不是
來 請助理跟我講一下
所以你看一下這個
明天凌晨的利率決策會議
當然這個台灣50季度調整
明天再講也可以
這是後天的事情
這是明天凌晨 這一定要講
因為明天早盤一開盤
就知道這個決策會議了
你想想看有誰做這麼漂亮
魔鬼藏在細節 好不好
有誰做這麼漂亮你告訴我
真的 我們美感也有差
為什麼用AI圖做得都特別漂亮
這是你要的
月曆怎麼拿
桌曆那時候
如果是那時候參加會員的人會有
OK嗎 不是每個會員有好不好
當然你跟我們
如果那時候你跟我們那個助理
撒嬌一下
如果是會員的話
應該先卡位有機會拿 好不好
行情是等出來的 沒有錯
就我剛才講的台積電
就等一下子然後噴出去
月曆可以買嗎
不賣 非賣品
好不好 無價的
這個月曆來不及了
這個都是11月的時候 OK嗎
桌曆可以加上大家的照片嗎
桌曆當然不能加
桌曆有加福利社的人的照片
智原和AI的關聯性
我已經有講過了 好不好
客製化的AI 好不好 OK嗎
這個講過很多次
其實我不太喜歡回答問題
因為我不太喜歡
就是都沒看我的節目
然後突然問問題
你應該先看我的節目
看個一陣子 好不好
可以申購月曆
台勝科和環球晶
肯定比做環球晶好
對 因為台勝科籌碼比較簡單
就像信昌電一樣
不會 都會拉起來好不好
夜盤噴噴噴
我剛才說空單很少 對不對 看一下
看這邊 噴217點
你們看一下
現在是46000 我們放大
看不到 不能往上移是不是
好 46264點
我們看大盤
46270 現在46270
這邊對不對
這邊可以放大嗎 可以
來 我們加個顏色
你看現在多少
46270嘛
你看下面多少
這看得到嗎 導播看得到吧
這是45000
差多少 差了400點
所以現在台指期多400多點
這是強烈做多的訊號之一
好久沒有正價差這麼多了
多400點以上 OK嗎
所以要找我們這種期貨分析師
我都不懂耶 為什麼
就是同樣的錢你為什麼
就像買蘋果手機一樣
很多人買蘋果為了追風
不是啦 貴有它的原因嘛
你說我會費貴 也沒貴多少
便宜的 然後讓你沒賺到有比較好嗎
好不好
當然股市它有漲有跌
它沒有一定
我們沒有什麼是一定
可是你不選最紅的要選誰
你看我隨便解釋一下
你不覺得就是深入淺出嗎
因為我們有期貨牌照
我們可以去解這些盤
你懂不懂
沒有期貨牌照就比較麻煩
OK嗎 這個跟大家講
來 你看助理馬上
你看 念它一下
馬上做好你知道嗎
來 這個跟大家講
0050季度調整有沒有看到
新增藥華藥
還是那個早就被剔除了
上一次被剔除了
就是我剛才講的康霈
還是怎麼樣
藥華藥
康霈是不是被剔除了
助理幫我查一下
藥華藥增加 然後剔除世芯
所以這個世芯最近比較差
前陣子比較差 現在沒有
還好 這個可能再持續
它有時候是這樣
一直跌下去 跌下去
等到被剔除那一天反而會長紅K
我以前是這種專家
我以前靠MSCI生效賺很多錢 OK
台灣50生效
以前還沒有那麼大權力
台灣50以前不到1000億好不好
以前MSCI的威力比較大
所以我從台灣50不到1000億
那時候剛開始 慢慢的
其實證交所員工賺翻了
我記得他們好像內規
他們福利金好像是
就是退休金是去買台灣50
所以越早加入證交所的員工越幸福
因為那都十幾二十倍了
退休金都十幾二十倍
0050是不是回不到
104 103的價格
可以啊 減資就可以了
股份減少就可以了
對 股份增加就可以了 來
這個不是重點
台灣50隨時買啦 OK嗎
明天看好逆勢上漲
就明天上漲的機率很高好不好
哲哲要提醒我們按讚
你不提醒我們怎麼記得
什麼都要提醒你們
成人社會 我就不提醒怎麼樣
改天我就收錢
改天我就把節目關起來
給那個有花錢
怪東怪西
是可以啦 好啦
不能怪東怪西的
跟你鬥嘴啦 來 我們看一下
看一下按讚人數
1800 可以啦
00403A
我不想研究那麼多ETF
買台灣50就好了 相信我 來
升息台股也不一定會跌
因為會怕的都跑了 對啊
所以我說升息不一定會跌
我剛才有講過
會怕的都跑了
所以明天反而利空出盡 好不好 來
蘋果18如果賣量好
鴻海才會好
是沒錯啦
我覺得最賣的會是摺疊機
你有沒有看到
這一次主流是摺疊機
它最近不是跟影視颶風
五月天 還有跟那個
蘋果新的CEO
他就說最厲害的
就是那個打開以後
好像書本一樣
從裡面翻到外面都是一致的
這個很難形容
很多影片有啦
裡面跟外面打開是一樣
所以會覺得好像
有影子的感覺
有疊影 有影子的感覺好不好
哲哲也會買啦 好不好
你們就不要跟哲哲搶了
沒有 開玩笑
因為我們今年那個
尾牙應該會送20支以上
的那個摺疊機
所以我們用團體訂購的
企業訂購一定是可以訂得到
OK 20支以上
很多人都要拗我要送幾支
我還在想
20支也要200萬 還在想
因為有些部分的錢拿去捐款救護車
還有別的捐款
還有慈濟捐款
我知道一定有人說
哲哲你幹嘛捐慈濟
我的想法是有捐總比沒捐好
每個人想法不同 來吧
我們來看一下
扯遠了
來 我們來看一下
所以今年經濟成長挑戰12%
這個都廢話
這都是舊的東西 不用看
那我們最後來看一下
我們念一下
這個行情真的很無聊
能像我這樣喇低賽
喇那麼久的人真的不多
看一下簡訊 好久沒講簡訊了
簡訊今天有一檔
因為精材今天表現不錯
看一下 念一下 美女念一下精材
好 9月16禮拜三 今天的簡訊
恭喜3374精材
股價表現不錯
尾盤急拉大漲
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺124%
財富翻倍
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
來 那AI
台灣股市漲到5萬都沒問題
只是漲5萬的過程中
甚至5萬到10萬的過程中
最大問題是通膨
這些股票都會漲上去
可是我跟你講通膨現在越來越嚴重
那只是逼著美國跟伊朗談判而已
只要真的確定談判了
建議和解了
我跟你講不好意思
那股市就怎麼樣
股市就有機會整個噴出去 OK嗎
這個我跟大家講
恭喜3374精材
你要去想一件事
其實現在通膨越來越嚴重
比3月的嚴重
那石油越來越缺
因為之前都戰備儲油
好 那如果再加個股市
因此而下跌
川普就有壓力了
所以有時候有跌沒有不好
因為川普一有壓力
這個戰爭兩個就可以
談一個中長期的確定的合約
我說美國跟伊朗
你要記得
川普是變色龍 再講一次
川普是變色龍
他最怕的是股市下跌
現在伊朗就賭這個東西
賭到最後你受不了
然後股市下跌
所以如果真的9到12月
因為美伊戰爭再次的下跌
他反而是你最後
最漂亮的加碼時機點
你一定要記得我這句話
因為那時候離和平
真正和平已經不遠了
離真正的噴出去已經不遠了
OK嗎 記得我這句話
那今天精材是噴出去
但是我最近比較看好是矽晶圓
矽晶圓看起來是真的要缺了
大家比較認同我的矽晶圓
精材也是
我說如果精材要跌破400我再加碼
我都不敢加碼
因為都漲太快了
你看幸好我沒追高
一追高你看買在496 慘了
又跌到400塊又被人家唸了
最近行情比較被唸
但是我跟大家講
我的績效還是比很多人好很多
因為我盡量不追高
我不會什麼CPO強講CPO
光電族群強講光電族群
記憶體強講記憶體族群
你會發現這個時候
這個行情不好做
你就發現什麼是老投顧
什麼是新投顧的老師
真的有差
做法 作風
天天漲停板 天天賺錢你相信
請你不要看我的節目
因為那是不可能的事情
我也不屑 我也不喜歡騙你
不好意思 我跟大家講
可是如果你說投資的品性也好
我絕對是
我自認為我是數一數二
而且有法院認證的
還是要跟大家講 法院認證的
來看一下
郭哲榮 簽結郭哲榮好不好
有沒有看到 簽結
寫給我 郭哲榮有沒有看到
郭哲榮君 還有我的律師
其中之一個律師
我們沒有明顯集中炒股的事情
有沒有看到
函請相關單位
偵緝大隊 證交所
多次
有誰像我這樣經得起考驗
我跟你講
如果一般老師有像我這樣的
喊股票的能力
可以隨便喊就漲停板
基本上我覺得大部分的人
八九成的人會偷偷買股票
會用人頭戶
我完全沒有
我不屑賺那種錢
我的念茲在茲的不是我賺多少錢
而是你賺多少錢
所以我就是很正向思考
那時候還有人搞個自救會
168啦
我告他 告到他這樣
我不知道是不是脫產
一毛錢都沒有
那他背後的勢力是誰
是不是同業 是不是分析師
那時候可以打廣告
現在一毛錢都沒有
贏了 我贏了
贏了30幾萬
贏了啦 公司加我
越講越生氣
每天一定要稍微講一下
結果要扣押他的財產扣不到
沒有關係 我相信他也後悔
沒必要這樣搞我
這市場沒有郭哲榮
還是有分析師賺錢
沒必要這麼氣
這樣不是很好嗎
把人家講得好像壞蛋
誰能像我這樣
我不敢說我是大好人
但是投資的品性
我覺得我是最高要求
這個跟大家講
股市無聊的時候看哲哲的節目
真的要看哲哲的節目
最近很無聊
你是老投顧
每日例行 鞭屍時間
一定要講一下 很氣
講個一分鐘 還不是有人廣告
我的節目是沒有廣告
我自己可以錄廣告了 好不好
講一下OK啦
最狂最有良心
不懂6000多人看 有4000多人
為什麼不去按那個讚
對啊 按個讚
沒關係 有些人就是這樣子
就是死不按讚
就是因為很多是同業看的
不按讚又怎麼樣
不會怎麼樣
下次我再提高3000個讚
提高4000個讚
然後哪天我就提早結束
我就逼那些人讚
其實哲哲不是
所以我說要玩心機我很會玩
只是要不要玩而已
我都知道怎麼做壞事 玩心機
我不想這樣做
下次就玩3000人讚
再一次玩4000人讚
那再來5000人讚很難達到
剛好提早結束 剛好休息
好啦 OK
散戶被洗的差不多 轎子要坐穩
對啊 這個漢測8000多要回來了
好不好 以後
抽籤拜託你們就是去開個質押戶
這是我的看法
抽籤不要拿救命錢去抽籤
就是那種可以動用的
臨時可以動用的
理財型房貸去動用的
這個我覺得還不錯
目前我想到沒什麼缺點
但是你的風險要自己處理
我只是沒想到什麼缺點 OK嗎
法院終於還投資長清白了
對啊 還有告贏
還有一件 好不好
同一位分析師的 好不好 來
按讚也是基本禮貌
沒關係 我們不用一直內耗
這只是聊聊而已
講幹話而已 好不好
一定有人喜歡我
一定有人不喜歡我
我很平常心
我會唸一下
但是我們趕快把
先把我的正事做完
聯發科好不好
看起來要噴出去
聯發科可以買
對 這個又拉回去
我當初一買又拉起來了 是不是
那個助理提醒我
我們可能再買一次
這個價位不錯
真的再買一次
2344華邦電也是一樣
在跌什麼東西 我都看不懂
不會啦
NOR Flash到時候有很缺
他的問題是
就是他漲很多 就這樣子
你看以前19塊而已
現在169
漲了8 9倍
華邦電也好 精材也好
我就是愛你們
我要讓你們知道
股票要抱久一點點
那個久不是很久
一年 如果就算一年抱一倍
都不算久
更何況有很多股票不用一年
可是你不能每天去看它
你每天看它你會很煩
你要每天看我的節目
你才會撐得住
很多散戶賺不了錢
第一個 買的張數太少
第二個 買了 一賠錢馬上走
最常走的是賠錢完以後馬上賺錢
總算不賠了 我馬上走
少賺後面的100%
少賺後面的100萬 1000萬
所以你要看我節目要怎麼樣
要去養你的心靈
什麼意思
要讓你的心靈寧靜下來
看哲哲的節目
泰山崩於前而色不變
這沒什麼 績效等久了就來了
真的跟大家講
前提不要融資好不好
久了以後你會發現到
我也沒在收什麼會員 沒什麼
所以要不要參加我們的會員
你自己參考一下好不好
世界先進最近比較怪怪的
有在漲了 有在漲一點點
最近紅K比較多
我的盤感蠻強的
當然他就是老
就是比較老派的股票
比較老的股票
跟老投顧沒有關係 好不好
所以哲哲不論對或錯一切的一切預告在前面
3532台勝科在拉
真的一個比較大的族群在拉
還有代表什麼
記憶體沒有問題
不是記憶體沒有問題
被動元件 不是
矽晶圓沒有問題
記憶體也沒有問題
被動元件 6173信昌電
算老式了 都要創新高了
代表是華新科 國巨沒有問題
被動元件沒有問題
記憶體更是沒有問題
記憶體最大問題是漲太多了
所以你為什麼不選
低基期的被動元件呢
600元以上的國巨你真的要珍惜
且戰且珍惜
矽晶圓1000元不到的環球晶要珍惜
可能台勝科要先噴出去了
也有可能台勝科走信昌電模式
老三 老四先噴出去創新高再說
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
年底要到了
年底要破5萬點
我認為是非常有信心
真的很有可能會達到的事情
所以歡迎來洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
記住LINE喔
上面有白色勾勾
最上面有白色勾勾
沒有白色勾勾
沒有藍盾牌白色勾勾都是假的
按了我的照片以後要寫已認證
不然其他都是假的 好不好
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我說
哲哲 我要參加會員
盡我所能來幫你賺大錢
明天就是台灣股市重要轉折點
趕快加入我們的行列
我愛你們 Byebye